[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablar de economía
aquí en france24 para eso me acompaña
jorge hurtado jorge buenas noches para
usted y empecemos hablando de la crisis
económica en serie' lata es que esta
semana el primer ministro de esa nación
dijo que la economía colapsó totalmente
el nuevo primer ministro decir y láncara
mil weed crema de zinc aseguró que su
economía se derrumbó y puso su esperanza
en un acuerdo de negociación con el
fondo monetario internacional la
situación económica es grave porque el
gobierno debe 51 mil millones de dólares
y es incapaz de pagar los intereses de
sus préstamos y mucho menos de conseguir
esa cantidad que está esta situación se
trasladó a las calles porque no hay
dinero para importar gasolina leche gas
de cocina y papel higiénico la moneda
local ha caído un 80 por ciento
encareciendo las importaciones y
agravando la inflación que ya está
prácticamente fuera de control el precio
de los alimentos ha aumentado hasta un
57 por ciento según los datos oficiales
la onu por su parte advierte que siri
lanka está al borde de una emergencia
humanitaria el programa mundial de
alimentos de la dice que casi nueve de
cada diez familias se saltan comidas o
escatiman para estirar los alimentos
mientras que tres millones están
recibiendo ayuda humanitaria de
emergencia escuchamos que decía el
primer ministro de esta semana
ahora nos enfrentamos a una situación
mucho más grave más allá de la mera
escasez de combustible gas electricidad
y alimentos nuestra economía ha
colapsado por completo y esa es la
cuestión más grave que tenemos ante
nosotros hoy jorge pero explíquenos esa
economía cómo llegó a ese punto porque
varios analistas que apuntan a factores
internos precisamente como años de mala
gestión y corrupción el malestar social
se centra ahora contra el presidente
rajapaksa y su hermano el ex primer
ministro may inda este último renunció
tras semanas de protestas
antigubernamentales que terminaron en
violencia un tercer hermano del
presidente también renunció al congreso
debido a la presión que recae ahora
sobre esta familia incluso antes de la
llegada de la pandemia en 2019 los
atentados suicidas de semana santa en
iglesias y hoteles que dejaron más de
260 personas terminó con el turismo una
fuente clave de divisas otro detonador
fue cuando el gobierno necesitaba
aumentar sus ingresos por el aumento de
la de la deuda externa para los grandes
proyectos de infraestructura pero en su
lugar
e impulsó los mayores recortes de
impuestos en la historia de la ncaa esto
hizo que las agencias calificadoras
rebajaran la calificación de sir lanka y
no pudieran acceder a más préstamos
rajevac se prohibió repentinamente las
importaciones de fertilizantes químicos
algo que agarró totalmente desprevenidos
a los agricultores y afectó las cosechas
de arroz de primera necesidad haciendo
subir los precios también la guerra en
ucrania hizo subir los precios de los
alimentos y del petróleo y que puedo
hacer entonces el gobierno decir y
lanzado teniendo en cuenta que hay un
nuevo primer ministro pero que el
malestar social continúa las calles
maría clara hasta ahora el gobierno lo
que ha hecho es sobrevivir con cuatro
mil millones de dólares en línea de
créditos de la vecina india pero ese
monto sólo servirá para mantenerse
durante seis meses más el gobierno
también estaba buscando más ayuda de
china otros gobiernos como el de eeuu
japón y australia aportaron algunos
cientos de millones de dólares
adicionales e incluso contemplan la
posibilidad de poder comprar petróleo
barato a rusia actualmente hay
conversaciones con el banco mundial el
banco asiático de desarrollo para
asegurar préstamos a corto plazo hasta
que reciben el apoyo del fondo monetario
internacional en este préstamo que
todavía se negocia jorges gracias por
este panorama en ser y lanza nosotros
pasamos a el debate a mirar más
información sobre el aborto en eeuu
[Música]